hey hey hey people um
it's louis i'm back again you know
mr lewis
what's your name
this is
the person in the whole world
i wasn't scared of the devil
i wasn't scared of a dog i was scared of
him and that wasn't my daddy
i was terrified of this man
and i came to my senses later on in life
he was the one who brought me into this
world
and the cause and effect of how he
treated me or didn't keep me as a child
it's taking me out
i'm going for it let me tell the story
when i was a kid
i remember i was always always i always
always felt different
i always felt like
i was too short i was too tall i was
scared everybody
i couldn't fight i couldn't play sports
i couldn't see
i couldn't write i couldn't read
and the worst part about it
i couldn't tell nobody
that i couldn't do these things
there's a reason for that
well
i started back
i went to
when when i first went to school back in
fifth grade
my grandmother had my cousin walking
down and
i imagine i got to class late
maybe it was 30 or 40 kids in there
that's why
i remember when i walked in the
classroom
eyes on me
everybody looked at me louis
for the first time in my life i was
what you called it terrified
i was [ __ ] terrified and i remember i
felt like
i felt like i was naked
and everybody when i walked in the class
looked in my dick that's how i felt
i turned around
and i ran out of there like the
[ __ ] devil and i remember i ran
home to my grandmother's house
i said grandmama i just
i was too scared i just couldn't go in
and do it
i said mama whatever you do man please
don't tell my dad
some kind of weight
lewis got word of it i knew i am i got
this [ __ ]
feet out of me
and i was five years old
terrified of my father
well as time went on
i guess i got about in the second grade
and
i never could grasp i don't for certain
i couldn't grasp what the teacher was
saying or i couldn't understand her
but i think
when the teacher started explaining
things to me i didn't i just didn't get
it
but i've never said nothing
push it down in the gut first thing i
put down i was afraid of my father and i
wasn't going to tell nobody
either when something hurt it
or when i didn't think i could do it i'm
going somewhere that anyway one day
my father got home from work
and i had some homework
i didn't know how to do it
he says she's bringing tears around the
pain the pain he says
did you do your homework
no man
i didn't know how to do it
god damn it do it
i just told him he didn't hear the first
part
so i went and did what i thought was
supposed to be done on it
showed it to him he got now he worked at
a club he worked in all of us in the
nighttime workers so he got home one
o'clock in the morning
one o'clock in the morning god damn it
you could hear me from my house to saint
louis he beat my he beat the [ __ ] i mean
he beat the [ __ ] black you looked at
my ass my ass was whiter than the one
most white person
well
so from way back then
i was to never tell him
i was to never tell him
when i couldn't do something cause i was
afraid i was gonna get the [ __ ] behind
me
so at school guys
at school kind of time if i kind of went
over to the
third and fourth as i remember when i i
i remember when i was when i was
maybe seventh eighth grade
i saw one of my report cards
now let me back up
my dad was so busy
[ __ ] hoes
now i can i'll give him this
financially and dressing he took cares
because he had money
but he never
he sent me
anything
anything i [ __ ] did
i did the wrong thing anything i said
i said the wrong way
but if i stoop down i stooped it up i
stood up i stood too high
i could never please this [ __ ]
and what brought that to my mind i was
watching the intervention that once was
i was watching the intervention one day
on the drug individual and the kid was
broken right and it was and it was and
his mother was telling the story he was
trying to please his daddy get his daddy
never said
i never heard of attaboy that's good i'm
proud of you never heard that [ __ ]
i heard
this
even all my family man to this day
if i see them doing something right some
good they're shaking their hair
as a child
that's what i remember
those are the things
that i bawled up in a ball and i put
them in this little bitty cutting i used
to be a skinny [ __ ] i just be
real skinny so putting too much in me
with one day i'm going to explode
and something else i pushed down in the
cut
now that all this [ __ ] muck up
nothing
time
let me i'm jumping around
now
i'm i'm a six-year-old kid
i got my lexie dude
that's your
[ __ ] a [ __ ] kid you when you
hear about a kid you molested me that's
that's you they think that [ __ ] is
serious i know i wouldn't throw up about
90 percent of what's been less
but when they did me like that that [ __ ]
[ __ ] me up
so the feelings that i'm stuffing down
when they're buying up that station and
all this [ __ ]
so
i just felt
a lot of pain angry frustration this i
just feel like an alien i feel like
every i
i'm a girlfriend i'm gonna go up in the
back i remember one one time i was
sitting down
when i was homeless
and i remember watching everybody the
people walk by
and people driving by any chaos and
porsches
nice to see
why can't i be like that i i feel like
i've always felt
like everybody else was living life and
i was just existing
there's somebody my family told me one
time as a child
don't ever tell no kid no [ __ ] again
he's just an obstacle
you're in everybody's [ __ ] way
you gonna tell eight your kids and [ __ ]
like that y'all they don't know who the
[ __ ] he is that's what so you telling
him who he is
and anyone and then when i got the pain
i can't tell nobody hurts cuz papa gonna
beat my ass so i'm stuffing this [ __ ] in
i'm stuffing this [ __ ] in
now i need some release
i can't beat nobody else cause i'm sad i
can't fight
i can't talk [ __ ] nobody cuz i'm scared
to hit me
the graduation party for high school
somebody handed me a joint
now the marijuana was okay
but then when later time come on
somebody bought me a bottle of
[ __ ] gym
i'm gonna say it like like the lady on
frank's friendship i took the hit of the
gin and i said all glory i have found
utopia i didn't feel scared no more i
could talk to girls i didn't feel no
more pain i didn't feel no more anger i
live for no more frustration i feel like
y'all now i feel like everybody else
i'm teen now
i'm team lewis for alcohol god bless me
i had no id still
that it would land me while i landed
right now i'll get there later
i took that drink
and the second one took me
and the [ __ ] ain't never let go
and i recall
my girlfriend's
was father was a preacher and his son
got in my car and he found a budweiser
cap
and he had that to his dad he said daddy
said louis drink beer
as a pastor whatever they turn around he
says son
you need to stop doing that
beer leads to other things
ominous warning i ain't listening to you
no i knows i i had no idea what i was
getting myself i think about a week
later
somebody introduced me let me let me let
me tell you about this somebody
interested to a woman
this woman let me tell you fellas when
she walked through the room the aroma
she smelled like just made you feel good
when she when she went when she when you
when you wanted to get someone you got a
warning just thinking about her wouldn't
make that that card
when you think about how big a ass was
supposed to be and let me tell you
something
all these things description i gave this
lady
you can't even see a
name every time i give you guys the name
of somebody in my family i always use
adidas with this one i'm gonna tell you
what her name is her name is cocaine
when i met that [ __ ]
she [ __ ]
she made me i took a hit off that
[ __ ] pipe
i felt like i was nothing on myself i
wanted if thank god well no way but i
think if a woman would have walked down
the street i probably would or i wonder
if i would have [ __ ] anything and
[ __ ] like i'm not exaggerating
i would have [ __ ] anything in sight
that's how good that [ __ ] made me feel
and i could i had no idea
what that [ __ ] was going to do to me in
my future
god knows i would have never [ __ ]
again
[ __ ] so anyway
i didn't know i had a problem
let me when i first
so it still it's life went on i i had my
little i
my
through my alcohol i started losing jobs
i started losing relationships
i started getting into people
people people started to tell me
maybe you have a problem
now i'm gonna get deep
i went to my grandmother
yes hi
i wanna first
i took eight hours to get up
my game over from school all right from
work
what's that with you i told her
what's wrong mama
i took it like i got high i think i got
a problem
but [ __ ] me up she wasn't even mad
it's okay baby cuz you told me the truth
she called my father
for the first time
for the first time
my father didn't want my ass
he thought about
what i'm going to tell you i'm now
i'm going my father started a new family
i got two step brothers
he put them through therapy he got them
psychologists he put one of them in
rehab now he runs to rehab
but me when i was a child
you ain't gonna never be nothing you
stupid
you dumb
i don't wanna hear [ __ ] you gotta say
i don't know what's gonna become of you
that's what the [ __ ] gave me
[ __ ] you beans [ __ ] physically
mentally but then little [ __ ]
you ought to see how they live so what
what did he
that day
he thought about that
i looked at that [ __ ]
and i said
you just might be fake
[Music]
he throws me in this detox center
some big high class you gotta touch him
detoxing
they had swimming pools the ice cream
river [ __ ] they watch goddamn
movies worth layering
but when you say that say that for four
months
then they send you to the rehabilitation
program
i've been to about 46 in the
[ __ ] in my life
but let me start for the first one
i get to the building there's this big
white villain and that's like the wall
there's a big white wall and the chairs
are centered real pretty and the plants
are all painted with everything sitting
there real nice
this thing won't be too bad everybody's
walking around like they're happy hey
how you doing shaking your hand i looked
up on the wall
up on the wall
the biggest there was there was
there was some steps on the wall
there was steps to recover i didn't know
that then but the first step
says we
admitted
that we were powerless over alcohol
the second part said and that our lives
had became unmanageable
now mind you
this is what i said man [ __ ] y'all [ __ ]
you [ __ ] my life ain't no matter
i ain't man well i i still got a car i
still gotta watch i still got a
girlfriend [ __ ] this [ __ ] i won't got
the [ __ ]
i never will forget that [ __ ] first
step
i don't want to i i know i i'm kind of
i'm kind of i'm kind of suspecting
myself i got some kind of a little
problem
but i didn't know the severity of it i
didn't i didn't know that step one was
was something that would that would
knock on my door today anyway
so
we all had these cars and just remember
i went to a class like to go to this
club i was by the beach and because i
liked them dad and they had in one room
so we would go over there and i remember
i said give me a lot of nice tea and the
guy said whoa
what you doing you can't drink
you ain't really how you what the [ __ ]
you mean i can't drink i got a problem
with cocaine i never run without alcohol
the location was [ __ ] me up the
cocaine will make me see my grandmother
not the alcohol
that to me to me there was a difference
he said man he said you haven't
surrendered to [ __ ] your tummy you need
to surrender dude you need to drink i
remember one guy told me that program
backing up he said
you still gotta watch you see what he
said he didn't say he said when i got
sober
i didn't handle watch
i didn't have no car
i didn't have no job that's why i got
this nasty stopping my pain during my
everything was dirty i was homeless i
just i didn't have i didn't have nothing
to get myself so
he was he was letting me know
because i kept i can't wait to do it i
can rehab here i can use i can't get rid
of really really
i just can't read absent so
[ __ ] that [ __ ] i ain't really gonna know
i'm still thinking i ain't really got no
problem
i had a girlfriend
she wanted to get a joint bank account
now
for those who don't know you'll never
get a joint bank account with a
crackhead i didn't know i was a
crackhead [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude
i live with her in her house
i smoked all that money up
her mother went to the store i just i
didn't know all at one time i just kept
going
and you know
when you smoke right you don't know what
the [ __ ] you just when you once once you
take a head
you you off and running and you don't
know where you're gonna land you take
you take you i call it once you take
flight you don't know where the [ __ ] you
going there you don't give a [ __ ] when
you land when you come now you don't
come down like ever you just you fart
on the ground you don't give up you
don't give a [ __ ]
why am i now
eddie come out the grocery store she
said
god damn it's just this this [ __ ] hurts
so bad this just hurts
i went to the bank today
all my money's gone
now my this lady she was like a mob she
was tall she was slim couldn't be here
it was really pretty she didn't hurt her
bike
look that [ __ ] gave me him up there on
her face she said
i'll come out these [ __ ] in new
york when i come out the [ __ ]
store
i want to know where my [ __ ]
money went and you better have a good
[ __ ] answer [ __ ]
i ain't in my life been scared of a
woman i scared that [ __ ] that day cause
she wasn't bullshitting
right
right she's up there in the [ __ ]
store and i'm thinking should i take off
and run should i leave should i what
should i do should i go jack somebody in
the parking lot to get some money i
don't know what to do
for the second time that's like i told
my grandfather
baby i gotta hide the kid
she said what
i've always been persuasive
some kind of way i persuaded her and
they're not putting me out i guess
because i told you
but
this is what i'm experiencing i'm just
gonna talk about my learning i'm
learning powerless
i told her
with everything that i had in me and i i
didn't lie i was as serious as i was
just i was as serious as i was as
serious as i was talking to jesus right
now
i'm never ever going to do nothing like
that no more
and i was just i meant what i meant what
i was saying i mean i'm just i'm keep
i'm putting the emphasis on because i
meant what i didn't i meant it
two days later i got a paycheck i come
home late i just smoked up all the
goddamn check
i kind of thought
do i have a problem nah i just want to
get high
he used to say she ended up putting me
out the house
my sister didn't like her
because she was she was i don't know how
the hell i got she was beautiful she was
beautiful she was beautiful
so they thought that she when she took
me from my grandmother's house and put
me in her house because she had those
two kids they thought she put me in her
to use me
she went in there because i was i was
good i'm a nice i'm i love kids i was
good they're kids i'm always good to
kids because i would see like [ __ ] i
love them all kids love me because i
played with them
so that's why she she i was good for her
kids i was a good babysitter and i could
[ __ ] them
but they they they thought she was using
me
i stopped giving her money and she
kicked me out
grandma my little sister should help
when i see her i'm a kicker [ __ ]
i said but i feel so bad because so
anyway i was my sister told me later
that she called her and said
your brother
is own cocaine
and he took all my [ __ ] money
that's why i put him out i was just
letting you know that my whole family oh
i still i didn't think i had that bad
problem
but when
that that that that was that was that
was when i was i was seeing power this
is so okay after that
i'm gonna go up and i'm coming
i would get my my check
on friday
i would [ __ ] it off
and i would say you know what
i'm not gonna do that you see
i'm not gonna i did it week after week
after week after week after week after
week after week after week after week a
week
after year after year i did it over and
over and over and over and over nah nah
nah
damn webster i could put this in
addition and doing the same [ __ ]
thing expecting different results every
time i tell because because i don't know
i'm powerless and i tell my am i here to
tell me let me let me tell you about the
committee
me and your friend my mom were talking
who i'm getting me a friend of mine were
talking
now he's been in the pen
maybe 20 years his life and i'm bragging
man i ain't even there let me [ __ ] that
man
i was sitting up the other day which was
this was gonna be depressed i was
sitting up the other day
not only have i been to prison
i went to the pen
on july when it was when i took that
drink of that damn
alcohol
i was put in prison that day
and when i
got 21
i'm at the two ceos of the prison
what what prison i'm talking about is
the prison inside my head the prison
inside my thinking and
this this this thing this thing is it's
broken
there's there's something in here
that don't for some reason it won't
allow me to to think about what i'm
doing when i'm before i go get the joke
until i get this open and walk home with
them what the [ __ ] did i do that's i'm
broke
and and
and when
wha what what
so this i got two ceos
and they
one of the last name is cocaine her last
name is is vodka and these two
[ __ ] tell me when to get up
tell me when they go to bed tell me when
to see tell me who the [ __ ] and every
now and then they take a day off
when they take it they're off i feel
like i'm normal
and then i let myself i talk myself well
i could go to the liquor store
and just get one [ __ ] beer i
don't know i get one
half fine again i never thought there
were one half ounce
one
i'll get you one for half out of you
i'll [ __ ] everything off
listen
i'm gonna tell y'all how pop where i'm
going i
at my apartment complex right now
i'm already behind
a month and a half i've got my i'm i'm
behind a month and a half of my rent
there's a connection
he'll come by the department complex
i don't have no money
and when i see him
he'll say what you need
you don't need no money pay me later
give me some credit he's like the long
shot he was throwing me at 20. i own 40
dollars
i'm behind all right
i'm behind on this
oh okay
let me go let me see now my now i got a
smart tv i love
the only thing really nice i got i got a
shot tv
my tv i talked i'm a good talker i
talked to people down the spectrum i got
thirty four dollars a month i get the
modem i get to see and i always
now my tv is the only out that i have to
all this [ __ ] i have gone in my life
when i my tv's my i could watch
i didn't i didn't pay my cable bill two
months ago no pretty much who i didn't
pay the cape bill 34 i smoked the 34
so they let me get away with that month
so the next month i said well [ __ ] it i
can smoke this month up too because they
and everything you know they shut the
goddamn cable off
so they sent me a [ __ ] net in the
mail sent home 445
i specs and i said whoa
i
i said well wait a minute
i said i i talked to me and said it's
okay he said well first just give me a
hundred give me a hundred twenty four
dollars and then you will turn it back
on thank god i gotta turn my cable back
on so now i'm sitting here thinking
about all this [ __ ] and
i'm gonna jump around
two days ago i was gonna come anywhere i
was i was leading up to that i'm getting
i've been so goddamn depressed behind
that [ __ ]
but
anyway i'm i'm getting to the power of
this i'm powerless
i am an alcoholic and a and a junkie
and what is
that's true and what that
i was sitting
on the bed crying
two days ago
god i'm never going left this is when it
really hit me two days ago
i'm thinking about what i'm going to say
when i come here
no notion you're getting high no notion
to get drunk
i get a [ __ ] knock on it oh
guess who it is that the [ __ ]
dog
is the connection
now wait a minute
five minutes ago
i'm picking up
oh this [ __ ] i'm gonna say but at five
minutes
next thing i know i had a twenty in my
hand sitting on the table twenty on a
rock
i sat on the bed
i see yeah
i'm powerless
for five minutes
i couldn't deny
that is the most [ __ ] up i think about
i suffer from disease alcoholism and to
me that's the worst disease in the world
i think a man with leprosy i think a man
i think a man that's born with a limb
going a man is born with one year or one
mile even even i'd rather have no dick
than to be a goddamn caught
i was to the point the other day
and i told god
god i don't really know who you are
i'm ready to get out of here i don't
want to be here
i don't like living i don't like your
life i don't like
to smell i don't want the weather
i don't have no friends i have no
girlfriend
the porno magazines are turning me down
my hand turns me down
i ain't got nothing
my hopes my dreams i have no hopes i
have no dreams i don't have no i don't
have no i don't have no i'll tell my
friend i didn't tell my friends
what you doing in the household you know
go out and also oh i know i don't have
no kid i can go so i told cox to god i'm
gonna take me out of here dude this is
this is real that's why that's why god
take me the [ __ ] out here
i said damn if i'm going to hell if i'm
going to heaven wherever the [ __ ] i'm
going just
take me out so i sat down in the bed and
i thought i said [ __ ] i got a whole
medicine cabinet through
now god knows my come on i'm too much of
a coward to do anything but i'm telling
you
i i i go to the to the medicine cabinet
look at all that medication they gave me
i got all the medications i get so
shitty [ __ ] that's what i think
take some bro i got all the medication
god damn them people professional i got
their medication goddamn because i
needed i'm about i mean
my brother took me out of the country
my brother took him out of the country
and he said i'm gonna take you out of
the country
to help you out because you're killing
your mama
what's your alcohol destruction so he
think he could take me out of country
and show me a different part of the
world which he did
but when i got down to the first thing i
said wait a minute where's the liquor
store
he said with the girls no no no no i see
them where's the liquor store
so
i was due to go down in the state for 30
days for two weeks he called mother said
he got to go home he ain't ready he said
he said
he's not ready for this
he's got to go home i'm going to send
him home because he's not ready
anyway
my family
they don't want me around
you know whenever
the other weekend i was just i was so
sorry to see my family my mother i don't
know what i said she was going to my
nephew's football game they're going to
take me with him she didn't call me i
called him brother they want to go hang
out to park my brother he didn't call me
back that [ __ ] man i should hurt us man
i mean i pray i don't need nobody
i'm so [ __ ] lonely up in that
[ __ ] house man i'm sitting in
the house and and i told god
i'm such a i'm such a coward man
some people somebody told my time be
careful what you have for i
y'all know around hey no distracting my
scissors i just like me i just like get
some cocky on me so i'm talking to god
well let me just if i talk to the guy if
you can hear me the guy i tell him just
like i'm talking to you i tell everybody
you gotta take it out i said man i need
i need to send me somebody maybe
something somebody that i could find
over that that guy that could that could
persuade me to get recovery or could
prepare me to do glory something to stop
me or want to make me want to live maybe
one exists
and god dammit the next day
i'm sitting down over this one spot
where i get food and i'm drinking the
rice tea
and you're going to this girl who walks
in frame now she's about the kind of
girl i pray for she walks this way and
she walks that way she walks to this
corner she wants to go and she walks
right across even when i'm sitting and
i'm leaving i'm looking at her she ain't
looking at me
what's his name she got a nice set of
legs you know i'm looking at
and i said hmm i just said to myself
under my that could be the one somewhere
as i walked across the street
she walked across the street so as i'm
going on this side she walks in the
front of me walk right there in front of
me
and i said under my breath i gotta my
self-esteem is no i said what's up
she turns around
what's up
this [ __ ] told me
she's too pretty she ain't gonna [ __ ]
with you you know you can't [ __ ]
nothing you can't [ __ ] a white girl
like that you might as well just keep on
walking what did i do i kept on walking
and then hit me because i got like when
i got home i said damn that might have
been with anybody maybe maybe i was
trying to
i think every time
you you have something to kind of throw
to your face even you don't need it just
let you know he's real but sometimes i
don't believe in him in other times i do
one thing let me tell some i don't know
if this is god i don't know
i'm going back to the state one i don't
know if it's a god
i don't know what this who made this
earth i don't know if that table's there
i don't know if i'm really here in
reality whatever one thing two things i
do know
in this world
they thought i'm a junkie
and an alcohol i don't need nobody to
tell me that [ __ ] i don't need nobody to
show me that [ __ ] i [ __ ] live it
i [ __ ] my life is still my i love my
i i live like an animal you know you
know and and the [ __ ] thing about it
is i'm used to it
i'm used to it
it's got to i mean i've i've got but let
me let me let me say something cut off
i'm gonna go
i have been
i just chucked it with the the prison
guards
i've been analyzing i've still been
going against i've still been going in
taco but i've been
paying atten just
analyzing myself
and and
my conscience is getting louder that's
what i'm saying my conscience is
starting to speak over the [ __ ] ceos
my unconscious like wait a minute
[ __ ] [ __ ] what they talking
about you need to look at look and look
into this they telling you to walk down
there to uni because when an hour
if you if you tell me don't this is the
description of it now if you tell me
don't walk down that street right there
because they got mines in the street
me and i'm gonna walk down anywhere to
get that bottle alcohol and i'm a boom
one of my ladies is blowing off so i'm
gonna come back over here and you're
gonna say i told you that you're going
to treat and what alcohol say
it blew my leg off that time but let me
show you how to do it
that's what an alcohol that's what i do
when i get when i take a [ __ ]
drink
let me tell them i keep wanting to cut
it off and i'm on i'm on every
i love my brother
i'm beginning to hate my brother because
he sounds like my daddy
i'll call him i just go don't when i
can't say babe april
before i take a drink
do you want me to come over there
i guess he's wondering why the hell
cause if i take a drink
before i go to your house
i'm never ever ever gonna make it
because
once i take a drink
i don't know where i'm at in i don't
know what i'm gonna do what i'm gonna
encounter
and people think that i
i heard a song
on the tv the girl said walk a mile in
my shoe
walk them out
in my shoe
you look at me so i don't tell me when
they somebody would tell me one day how
are you good you you know i look at you
every time you come on youtube how could
you get on youtube
i want to say [ __ ] about your
damn show listening to it
but anyway well people think you got a
problem with the [ __ ] i'm saying let me
tell you something
i'm gonna tell you why i come down here
all this [ __ ] that i be feeling
when i come here and i share it on the
youtube
i get about this [ __ ] seat
and even
even for a day
i don't feel right
i get relief i'm gonna say this and i'm
gonna shut up somebody told me one time
why don't you take a drink again before
you go in there you'll feel better
this hit me i'm gonna say [ __ ] this hit
me like a ton of [ __ ] bricks
everywhere i go since i took a drink
before i go there i think about getting
a drink because
this is the only place i come and i have
never
even thought
about getting a goddamn ring before i
come in here
and it hit me like a ton of [ __ ]
bricks i said whoa
just i need to look at that
because when i come up in here
i'm getting real
i'm dealing with this [ __ ] i'm not
totally running off with it so i don't
need to do it to come in so i got to
thinking
maybe that's
that's why god is calling me into a new
lifestyle maybe that's where he he's
using me to help us i don't know but
it's something to that if i don't feel
like dreaming before i come here i i
can't think of nowhere else
that i don't think about drinking other
than church
there's only two actually going and
coming here i have never ever thought to
go get here before i came here
so as long as my people go ahead i do
when i was going through all my [ __ ]
i was feeling like crawling up in the
ball and going and dying or whatever
and someone said call yours
and get your ass to the seat
[ __ ] okay my name is louise and i see
you guys
you